Mō tātou, a, mō ka uri a muri ake nei
If you’ve visited the Regeneration Reserves
area recently, you will have noticed the huge
changes taking place here.
All this activity is known as the 'enabling
works'.
It’s getting everything prepared for the
various recreational facilities that will
be constructed here, and it’s got three
main components.
The first work package is the Beswick Storm
Management Water area, that is the installation
of a new storm water basin.
The second package is the earthworks that
you can see going on behind me here.
So it’s the importation of about 50,000
cubes of fill, to create a level playing field
for the new sports pitches.
And the third work component is the decommissioning
of the roads and utilities.
The scale of the work is huge, and expected
to take about eight months.
Overlapping that, construction of the facilities
such as the sports fields, dog parks and BMX
track will be getting underway.
Trent Jones grew up riding on the old Kaiapoi BMX
track, before eventually representing New
Zealand in BMX at the Rio Olympics.
He’s currently overseeing the rebuild of
the North Canterbury BMX Club track, and will
design the new track in Kaiapoi.
To the general eye, it’s just looks like
some dirt and some piles here and some piles
there, but the shapes and the design and final
features are very specific to our sport.
The proposed track will be wide enough for
four bikes at a time and Trent has some key
factors driving his design.
My first thought it fun, that’s obviously
the endgoal – to have has much fun as possible.
Safety is the second one and then being able
to cater for that wide spread of skill level.
You’ve got everyone from five and under
all the way through to 55 plus that can attend
and have that thrill of riding the bike and
challenging themselves.
Construction of the BMX track is scheduled
to start early in the new year.
While we’re aware this area has been popular
for walking and cycling, it’s really important
that people stay clear of the worksite – for
their own safety and the safety of our contractors.
We'll take another look at progress here and
at the Marine Precinct
in our next update.